hi I'm Jackie Chan I'm going undercover
in the Internet this is actually me all
right I'm ready
Yahoo Answers what is Jackie Chan's
secret what's my secret have no secret
everybody know where I'm born when I'm
follows the way for me I have no secret
I want some secret how did Jackie Chan
die Jackie Chan never die yes somebody
looking after me
probably my father my mom entered who
trained Jackie Chan when I was young my
master trained me 10 years after the
massage school I trained myself morning
cloudy afternoon
Aikido at 9:00 boxing meet of the nine
cup club so this way I can live 80 years
old looks like of 60 YouTube I think
you'd be very good in a romantic role I
don't know you should be offered that
role
- oh no what's that - like you - oh I
swear Jackie should be a comedian yes on
this earth [ __ ] and Jackie Chan have
the same accent no he's accent is more
I'll be bad my answer is still like a
baby quite sexy
I watched 200 Jackie Chan movie and yet
I still can't catch a fly use a
chopstick nobody can do that
that's in the movie nobody can't catch a
fly with chopstick nonsense don't try at
home Twitter
I thought Jackie Chan was retiring no
movie business so fun if I'm not in
front of the screen probably I'm gonna
be a director I can be a stunt
coordinator and also I can open a school
how I never retire you think Jackie Chan
is going star in an action movie and let
someone do or his sister
it depends every I try I cannot do it
I'm just not going to do it maybe I let
someone do a little bit but mostly I do
it myself
officially answer I was checking Chen
was my grandpa I think I'm a so many
people grandpa and brother and father
and I'm your family actually next
answers.com what this Jackie Chan
favorite stunt so many I've been making
more than 200 films probably project a
jump to the rooftop police story jump to
the shopping mall super cop John to the
helicopter
oh that's too many can I remember post
it does Jackie Chan live in Mexico
no Beijing but I had office in Shanghai
Taiwan actually I'm living around the
world answer what is Jackie's her
favorite color black yes Instagram this
is actually me oh wow it's an honor but
don't tattoo in your in my face in your
body really I mean your body in your
whole life so thank you that picture
looks very very old just exactly like a
foreigner the movie yeah I am probably
when I get old I would like that sent
for what is in line to meet Jackie Chan
right after the set I just ordinary
people very humble very lovely everybody
want to test me every day what they want
to touch me but not in the set in the
set I'm like a monster what are Jackie
Chan hobby honestly sit down with all my
scriptwriter negotiate a different
script and after the training spar with
my JC team I think just probably my
hobby
does Jackie Chan have a protege hard to
say I have so many they all have my
Jackie changing they all good yeah they
awkward what Marshall hostile that's
Jackie Chan no when I was young I
learned southern style northern style
and after that I learned when Joan
Hapkido karate boxing all kinds of
things so my style is chop suey
everything give me some more I am dd3
Mars lies give the thumbs up mostly does
his own stunts slapstick humor ready I
think Jackie is immortal what you think
actually no I'm not immortal
I just ordinary people I just have the
guts to try everything I can have so
many times digitized who will win Jackie
Chan or Bruce Lee Bruce Lee win let him
win I said now the internet knows
everything about me no secret